should be something oh and
many things happened in our main game
magnus carson was black against waiter
sheik he played f6 bishop g4
he didn't take only five we're expecting
that f5
it takes maybe he was afraid of some
bishop h4 now
that could go on very fast actually yeah
for for white took on f5
takes takes and this is very very
interesting position
wow peace sacrifice by
radek for itashik
and they say bishop h4 is the move
that cece is recommending
in the chat chat 24 chat i'm reading it
hello everyone welcome
so yeah bishop takes h4 if takes
then what's uh double please sacrifice
apparently
probably something like that
that looks could you be scared yes it
looks so scarier
to say the least even for luke it looks
okay
can you imagine
[Music]
but is it it's clearly difficult to spot
no
but i think um if you
if you look at the position in a
logical way uh i mean black has to do
something yeah at some point yeah
because h7 is hanging
to page six but if you let
me just i mean it's not not it's not
even about the material but it's like
black species they they're going nowhere
and
and i think magnus he's not this kind of
a passive player with just hero
he will look for some violent um
solution
is it something we should uh have a look
at
check i guess taking on f on c8 looks
way too dangerous again with these
pieces yeah no no no
check check and take on d5 check and
take on d5 yeah
so it looks very natural to me
check king g2 yeah i know some
yeah now it's a problem man because
queen b6 i just take on
nature i think i have no choice here
take on h4 knight t1 no
or not d1 yeah
this could go wrong king h3 has to be
played i guess
queen s2 mhm
queen queen e4
clean f1
and here we go flanking
maybe it's fine for white yeah
maybe even too fast yeah